All right.
So today I'm going to give my second
and final lecture on the human stain,
my first lecture focused on identity.
And my final argument about the novel in
relation to the question of identity is
that the first half of the novel comes
down on the definition of identity
through secrecy.
That what makes you who you are anyway,
what makes Coleman the
person he is is his secrecy,
who he really was,
was his secrets.
So I did that little
reading of that phrase.
Today I want to talk about what happens
in the second half of the novel to the
question of secrecy and how that relates
then into the question of desire and
narratives. So that's
where I'm going today. Um,
if you'll recall on page 47 I don't
think we need to turn to this. Um,
desire is said to be generated by the,
the human discrepancies,
the difference between Fanya with her,
uh,
illiterates vocabulary and Coleman
with the vocabularies have to ancient
languages and his language of English.
So discrepancy difference is
understood as the engine of desire.
So this shouldn't be surprising
when you think about what desire is.
Uh, many psychological
theories of desire, uh,
agree on one thing and that is that desire
is reaching towards a lack of desire
is generated by lack.
So you can think of difference as one
version of what it means to lack what you
are not.
You then desire what you have not you
then desire so you don't desire that thing
which you already have.
So it's just a simple structure of
desire that I want you to keep in mind.
Now I want to note in the second half
of the novel something that you probably
noticed at the beginning of chapter four,
we are plunged back into
Nathan's first person voice.
So that I have Nathan comes back very
strongly at the very beginning of that
chapter.
We haven't seen it for a while.
We've been embedded in Fanya and less
and Delphine and Coleman inside all their
minds using that technique of free and
direct discourse where the narrative
voice just sort of seamlessly allows
you to look at the world through that
character's eyes and in
that character's mind.
So that technique is highlighted as a
technique in chapter four when we are
reminded. So suddenly that this
is all being written by Nathan,
that the illusion of these characters
is just that it's an illusion.
The second half of the novel then
sets up the source of the story.
How does Nathan know all that
he knows to give us that story,
sets up the problem of that source.
And then it finally answers it in
the person of Ernestine's. Silk.
Yeah.
Ernestine Coleman sister answers some
of those basic questions about Coleman's
background.
First of all,
revealing his racial secret simply by
her presence at the funeral and her
resemblance to his daughter,
Lisa.
So her body is a kind of revelation to
Nathan and then she fills in some details
that we can see recapitulate material
that has come in an imaginative form,
different imagine a two
form earlier in the novel.
So I would note, and I
will come back to this, uh,
this point,
Ernestine is kind of a stock character.
There are some characters in this novel,
uh,
Delfin to some extent less and Ernestine
who are stereotypes of one kind or
another.
Okay.
There are various ways of thinking
about this problem in Roths fiction.
Uh,
the critical way of thinking about
it is that his fiction is uneven,
that he cannot somehow truly inhabit the
complexity of some kinds of characters.
And he has said about his own work that
he writes novels about the lives of men
very clearly masculine fiction.
So that should come as a prize,
as a surprise to none of you. Um, so
that's one way of understanding the,
uh, sort of cliched quality
of characters like Ernestine.
I'm going to offer a slightly different
way of understanding that, uh,
by the end of the lecture,
so be looking for that.
But for now I just want to focus on
the structure of the second half of the
novel,
setting up the problem of knowledge and
then producing it a part of an answer to
it. But even though you
have that partial answer,
there's still a residue of functionality
within the logic of the novel.
Of course it's all fiction,
but within the logic of the novel,
we know that there's a lot
that Nathan is making up.
So Ernestine story doesn't get you
Stena dancing at the end of, so,
uh, Coleman's bed, for instance,
a very important scene in
Nathan's construction of Coleman.
Yeah.
Um, so there are scenes like that that
are purely the product of Nathan's
imagination.
You have the final spasm of this kind
of imagining when Nathan's stands at
Coleman's grave and asks him to speak
to him one last time and tell him the
story of telling Fanya his racial.
So you have that last scene where we
enter fully into the minds and voices of
those characters.
Okay.
One question that you want to ask here
is how we should understand this move.
Is there something perhaps duplicitous
about the way Nathan root suggests he's
related to this enterprise of imagining?
We're told on page three 37 right
before that grave side scene that it was
Ernestine's
speaking to him that caused
him to be seized by his story.
This is in the middle of the page.
Um,
I was completely seized by his story
by its end and by its beginning.
And then in there I began this book.
So we get an account of it start.
So he seized by the story.
It puts him in a position much like he
is at the very beginning of the told
story that you've just arrived
at the end of when Nathan,
when,
um,
Coleman shows up at his door demanding
that he write the story of the unjust
dismissal from Athena College.
So there are two moments when Nathan
claims to be seized by Coleman and his
story,
it puts Nathan in a very passive position.
It suggests that he's not
the active party here,
that somehow he has been
drawn into this enterprise,
into this narrative,
maybe against his will.
I think you can see this as duplicitous.
So I want to look a little bit at how
this is duplicitous and this is where
desire comes back into
the braid of my argument.
Is that a sentence on page one 60 a four,
I want to direct your attention to,
okay.
Desire that
urge to and habit or fill
the lack of whatever it is.
How's a structural relation
to language in Roths work?
So desire has a structural relation to
language and I think there's no better
example of it and there's perhaps
no better example of Roths,
um, uh, ecstatic sentence structure.
Then this sentence on one 64
and I will read the whole of it.
Um, it starts the kid, you see it
about a quarter of the way down,
halfway through a line.
The kid,
this is about [inaudible] the kid whose
existence became a hallucination at
seven and a catastrophe at
14 and a disaster after that,
whose vocation is to be neither
a waitress nor a hooker,
nor a farmer nor a janitor, but forever
the stepdaughter to a lascivious,
his stepfather and the undefended ops
offspring of a self obsessed mother.
The kid who mistrust everyone sees the
con in everyone and yet is protected
against nothing.
Whose capacity to hold on
on intimidated is enormous.
And yet who's purchased on life is minute
misfortunes, favorite embattled child,
the kid to whom everything loathsome that
can happen has happened and who's luck
shows no sign of changing and yet who
excites and arouses him like nobody since
Stina not the most, but morally
speaking, the least repellent person.
He knows the one to whom he feels drawn
because of having been aimed for so long
in the opposite direction because of all
he has missed by going in the opposite
direction and because the underlying
feeling of rightness that controlled him
formerly is exactly what is propelling
him now the unlikely intimate with whom
he shares,
no less spiritual than a physical union
who is anything bought a play thing upon
whom he flings his body twice a week
in order to sustain his animal nature,
who is more to him like a comrade
in arms than anyone else on earth.
Wow.
That's quite a grammar.
What you see in that sentence
is language trying to embody
desire by its very excess.
It's acting out formally,
just how far Coleman has to reach
from where he was to arrive at steam,
at a Fanya as his object
of love and desire.
And you see that missing
lack is thematized in the middle of this
sentence because of all he has missed
by going in the opposite direction.
She embodies everything he isn't.
And the grammar of that
sentence relentlessly tries
to fill in to reach towards
who she is.
And that's why I think it's this.
It's a repeated noun phrase.
That's the grammar of the
sentence and repeated noun phrase.
So you just have piles of descriptions
of Fanya and now let me see if there's
any, if there is a no, there
is no verb, there is no verb.
This is a sentence fragment people,
this is a sentence fragment.
You can't find a verb for the subject.
So it's quite a remarkable feat of grammar
and it embodies the formal quality of
language as desire.
But it's more than
just at the level of grammar or at
the structural level of language.
That desire and language, um, coincide.
It's also there in the
way sex is imagined.
As auntie metaphorical.
If you look on page two or threes is one.
Fanya is dancing, uh, for Coleman.
And she insists when Coleman
wants it to mean something,
I guess she's just about to dance for him.
When,
when he wants their sex to mean something.
Uh,
she says, no, it's just
what it is. He said to her,
this is more than sex and flatly,
she replied, no, it's not.
You just forgot what sex is.
This is sex all by itself.
Don't fuck it up by pretending
it's something else.
What Coleman's urges is to use language
to make sex into something other than it
is to make meaning out of it.
That's a fundamentally
linguistic enterprise by
insisting that it can't be made
into something else. It puts sex not, uh,
so much,
uh,
outside of language as it elevates
sex to the equal of language.
So just as the grammar of the sentence
reaches out to fill that lack sex does
that too,
but it doesn't require the resources
of language to be successful.
So you don't need language.
Really.
All you need is sex to
produce that human connection,
that desire, uh, seeks.
So it elevates sex.
Okay.
Um, sex is the analog to
writing and other ways to,
uh, on page 37, um,
he talks about Nathan talks about
sex as the mania to repeat the act.
And he also talks about the language
tasks that go along with it.
This is on the top of 37 when he's
talking about why he withdrew from life.
Uh, I couldn't meet the cost
of its clamoring anymore,
could no longer marshaled the wit, the
strength, the patients, the illusion,
the irony,
the art or the egotism,
the resilience or the toughness or
the shrewdness or the falseness,
the dissembling,
the dual being,
the erotic professionalism to deal
with its array of misleading and
contradictory meanings.
So sex always comes along
with those meanings.
And Nathan could not separate out the
two in the way that Coleman succeeds in
doing with Fanya in finding an
illiterate woman. I think it's,
it's her illiteracy in a sense
that enables the separation
of sex from language.
Uh, but that may need to repeat.
The act looks a lot actually like,
like Roth's writing.
Roth is an extremely repetitious
writer across his novels.
His novels often engage the
same kinds of characters,
sometimes the same character, lots
of Nathan Zuckerman novels, uh,
even the ones that are not
Nathan Zuckerman novels. Uh,
look like Nathan Zuckerman novels.
You usually have someone who looks like
Nathan. Um, the women are often, uh,
often look the same.
They often rant in similar ways.
So there is something about Ross writing
that is close to that mania to repeat
the act.
So there you get that parallelism again.
Okay.
So the distance between one person and
another is crossed by language and by sex
in two equal tracks.
But it's also crossed in this
novel by the imagination.
And this is where the entering into
a Coleman story comes into play.
Now you will have noticed
at a few jarring points that
suddenly you'll be in free and
direct discourse in the third person.
And suddenly the eye of that character
appears. And there's an example on one 65.
This is Fanya at the bottom of the page.
She's thinking about the crow.
Yeah,
that cruise voice, she remembers it
at all hours, day or night awake,
sleeping or insomniac had a strange voice,
not like the Voice of other crows,
probably because it hadn't
been raised with other crows.
Right after the fire I
used to go and visit.
You see that I coming very suddenly there.
So why does it appear?
Well,
this is a moment when Nathan as the
writer takes an unusual liberty,
makes an unusual claim on us as readers
by entering directly into the first
person of this character,
violating what has been the formal habit
of the novel up until that moment where
the formal habit of that scene
and happens on a few occasions.
So he becomes the,
I have fanya
now you might say that this is just to
emphasize the imaginative work that's
required for Nathan to tell this story,
but I want to suggest that there's a
structural relationship between Nathan and
fauna that we have to attend
to and to to excavate this.
I want to go back to that first dance
scene on page 27 with Coleman and Nathan.
This is when they start to talk about sex.
And this is Nathan's reflection.
The moment a man starts
to tell you about sex,
he's telling you something
about the two of you.
I'm going to,
man starts to tell you about sex.
He's telling you something
about the two of you.
It's quite a remarkable statement.
It's homoeroticism should
not be lost on you.
He's telling Nathan about sex with Fanya.
But how Nathan here is it is
that it's about him and Coleman.
Now,
I don't mean to say that it literally
becomes about the fantasy of sex between
literal sex between Coleman and Nathan.
But I will point out a couple of things.
One is that Nathan,
if you recall,
has been rendered impotent by his surgery.
So his only relation in
that physical way to,
uh,
to Coleman is not really
as a man has such,
I think he's imagined to
be unmanned in this scene.
So
then you get on page 43 and
even fuller description of this.
Yeah,
he's talking,
Coleman is talking again about Fournier.
And Nathan is very much
responding in the conversation.
We were enjoying ourselves now.
And I realized that in my effort to
distract him from his rampaging peak by
arguing for the primacy of his pleasure,
I had given a boost to his feeling for me.
And I exposed mine for him.
I was gushing and I knew it.
I surprised myself with my eagerness
to please felt myself seeing too much
explaining too much over involved and
overexcited and the way you are when
you're a kid and you think you've found
a soul mate in the new boy down the
street, and you feel yourself drawn
by the force of the courtship.
And so act as you don't normally do and
a lot more openly than you may even want
to.
But ever since he had banged on my door,
the day after IRS is death and propose
that I write spooks for him. I had,
without figuring or planning on it,
fallen into a serious
friendship with Coleman silk,
the language of courtship and of gushing
of that overeagerness suggest to crush
it,
reinforces the homo erotic
charge of their dance.
And the way Nathan observes his
[inaudible] body as they danced together.
And it gives it that, um,
that emotional dimension.
So we're told of Coleman in
another spot in this, uh,
basic scene that he's
contaminated by desire alone.
Nathan,
if he is seized by Coleman story as
we're told at the end of the book,
is contaminated to by that
story and by desire for Coleman.
So just as that stepping over into the
first person from free indirect third
person discourse,
stepping over into the eye
of his character represents
crossing a certain kind
of boundary.
So does the erotic charge that is
given to his relationship with Coleman.
Now there are a couple of ways of
thinking about that homoerotic structure.
One is through the work of a
critic named Eve Sedgwick. Um,
and if you've taken any women's and
gender studies courses are studied, um,
a feminist interpretations or queer
interpretations of literature,
she should be a familiar name. She
wrote a famous book called between men.
And her argument is that in a lot of,
I think her subject was Victorian
fiction in a lot of Victorian fiction,
the homo erotic or the homo social
bond between men is channeled through a
woman.
And the perfect example of that in this
novel is when Coleman and Nathan go to
the dairy farm to watch Fanya.
So it's as if by both watching
funny together through her,
their desire for one another is channeled.
So they're able to experience
desire together and it
safely, not for each other.
Because funny is right there
as a mediating a f, uh,
point of the triangle.
But I think we can say some other
things about this structure to, um,
and not just that it's there.
Essentially Sedgwick's um,
theory allows us to see how it
works to see that it's there.
But then we want to ask why,
and this is related to what another
feature of the texts that you might have
noticed. And that is the repeated
reference to Thomas Mons death in Venice.
Did you notice that it comes back?
Todd Zeo and Aution Bach are the two
characters from Mons death in Venice.
This is a mid 20th century
German novelists. This is
a small novel will develop.
Um,
it's about an older man named Ashton Bach
who goes to Venice for a vacation and
he's a scholar and a writer.
And he goes to Venice and he suddenly
finds himself transfixed by a beautiful
young boy that he sees at the hotel.
And he spends the novel chasing Todd Ceo,
the boy all around the city
and trying to get close to him.
And the mother realizes the mother of
Tazio realizes there's this sort of
lecherous man coming after
her boy and warns him the, uh,
Todd CEO to stay away from
Austin Bach. Uh, in the end, I,
Bach is, uh, is taken
with a, I think it's,
um, a tuberculosis or some disease.
I can't remember what the diseases,
and he dies in Venice.
This passion for the boy is
described. And this is the, the,
the part that Roth quotes in this novel
as a late adventure of the feelings.
So in those quotations,
Roth is directing us to think about
the lateness of that desire as its
characteristic quality.
It's an older man suddenly waylaid
by an unexpected surge of passion.
Now,
what I find interesting about that is
that rock could have chosen any number of
romantic stories to characterize.
This Hummer would be one,
uh, late adventure of the feeling.
An older man, younger woman,
why does he take a homo erotic structure?
Why does he choose this story?
A story of same sex desire rather
than a heterosexual desire?
Why is this the model that he chooses?
So I would suggest it's important that
the novel is called death in Venice that
[inaudible] dies.
There is something about homo
erotic desire and this is, you know,
a characteristic of fiction
that features it, uh,
over the centuries that it seems deadly.
Somehow it's deadly.
It's imagined as being deadly.
Of course,
this is a product of its
unconventionality in older times.
Um,
the fear that a heterosexual person or
a person who conceives themselves as
heterosexual might experience if
they are taken by a homoerotic urge.
So there's somehow that death gets wound
into stories of homo erotic desire and
the human scene is no different.
Um,
just want to point out,
uh,
a couple of examples.
Um,
you can see it in the difference between
the way Nathan describes his decision
to dance with Coleman and the
way funnier describes hers. Um,
this is funny.
A on two 26.
Okay.
Uh, this is just right in
the middle of the page.
She's playing with her hair. Um, and
thinking that her hair is like seaweed,
a great trickling sweep of seaweed,
saturated with Brian and what's it
cost her anyway? What's the big deal?
Plunge in, pour forth. If this
is what he wants, abduct the man.
Ensnare him won't be the first one
that's Fanya sort of thinking why not?
Why not dance as he's asking me?
Why not?
What's the big deal?
What does it cost her?
Contrast that with on 25 and
26 the way Nathan thinks,
what the hell?
I thought we'll both be dead soon enough.
And so I got up and there on the Porch
Coleman's silk and I began to dance the
Fox trot together.
And if you look on 26th,
do you get another description where
death comes back up as a reason?
Um,
maybe why it didn't even cross
my mind to laugh and let him,
if you wanted to dance
around the porch by himself,
just laugh and enjoy myself watching him.
Maybe why I gave him my hand and let him
places arm around my back and pushed me
dreamily around that old blue stone floor
was because I had been there that day
when her corpse was still warm,
that's irises corpse and
seen what he looked like.
The corpse pops up in the middle of
this reflection on why he's dancing.
So two times in the space of a page,
death accompanies his decision
to dance with Coleman.
So why then
is
homo erotic desire such a threat,
a threat in this way? Well,
one structural reason could be that homo
erotic desire threatens to collapse the
engine of desire,
which is difference.
The novel has set up difference
being the engine of desire.
So if its desire for the
same understood as gender,
the important sameness being gender,
then
it looks like a self canceling desire,
a desire that can sustain itself
somehow or that lacks that fundamental
structure of difference that
the whole novel seeks to set up.
If desire is the engine of the sentence,
as well as the engine of the narrative,
as well as the engine of
human connection in the novel,
it's collapse is a great threat,
not just to human connection to
human life, but to write him.
So this was one way to understand the
problem and it goes back to speak to my
point about inhabiting
or being a parasite.
Upon Coleman story,
Nathan inhabits the eye and finally
begins to conflate himself with Coleman
or with Coleman's lovers.
And we get various versions of this.
So while,
um,
while Fanya and Coleman Dance,
he replaces, uh, let's see,
he replaces less.
So while they're dancing in the cottage,
do you remember the scene? I can't find
my page number on my notes right now. Um,
while he is,
while he,
while they are dancing in Coleman's house
privately, this is after Coleman, uh,
stopped seeing Nathan.
He's outside in his car
lurking on the road.
The only other person who
does that is less Farley.
So he comes to be in the position
of Fournier's other lover.
Okay. So that's one way he enters into
his characters as he starts to occupy
structurally the same spot as they do,
but it actually gets much more, um,
complicated.
This is on three 26
in Ernestine's conversation in her scene.
She is very helpful to say,
well then,
because Coleman Nathan has said, I've
been, uh, trying to figure out Coleman,
well then she says, you are now an
honorary member of the silk family.
So there he is,
taken right into the silk family.
So he starts to replace Coleman after
Coleman's death at the very end,
as he's getting
into the car to drive down to New
Jersey for dinner with the silks,
he says,
um,
let's see.
Uh, let's see. Like Stina
Polson before me, uh,
he was going to sit with his east orange
family as the white guest at Sunday
dinner.
He become Stena in that passage.
He becomes funnier when
he dances with Coleman.
He leeches into all the
aspects of coalmines life.
So it's not just inhabiting imaginatively,
but there are these structural ways.
He comes to double Coleman
and also to double his lovers.
It's by virtue of a blankness that Nathan
sees in Coleman and in Fanya that he
can pull this off.
And this is very noticeable in my
favorite scene of the novel that the
Tanglewood scene,
which I think is quite beautiful.
This is on two nine to 10.
He's running about, um, music here
and the feeling that all
the people in the audience,
we're going to be swept away by deaf.
That's sort of an overwhelming sense
of mortality in the beginning of the,
at the beginning, in the middle of
the page there, and he says, um,
and yet what a lovely date is today.
A gift of a day, a perfect day,
lacking nothing in a
Massachusetts vacation spot
that is itself as harmless and
pretty as anything,
as any on earth.
I would suggest that it's precisely
that lacking nothing that makes it
definitely, because if you lack
nothing, there is no desire.
So it's very status of the day and the
solidity of that music that brings him
into this mood.
And then Bronfman appears the pianist
and you get this wonderful description of
what he does,
how he attacks the piano and banishes
death with his contention with the piano.
And it should remind you of all that
sad about life being an argument.
I remember I mentioned last time Coleman
saying that all Western literature
begins with a fight, with an argument
between Achilles and Agamemnon.
Coleman's fight with the College Coleman's
fight against the racial contract
drawn up for him at birth.
Nathan's contention in the world of,
of desire,
which he then withdraws from,
he implants in his own
narrative of his thoughts.
What Nathan, what Coleman will
later say. This is on two 11.
Uh, he's Coleman says, I was
telling funny that he took 10 years,
at least out of that
piano. Nathan had said, uh,
on the previous page that they would
have to throw that thing out after
Bronfmans finished with it.
He plants in the narrative.
The shared thought asserting that
somehow Kohlmans mind is Nathan's mind.
That collapse is written right into
the realest assumption of the novel.
We sort of read along in those
passages thinking, oh, you know,
let's take this at face value. Oh
yes, they're thinking the same thing.
But of course it's Nathan who plants that.
It's Nathan who's making it up.
We don't know how honest Nathan is.
So he claims to have the same thoughts.
It's the blankness.
He describes Nathan,
I mean a Fanya and Coleman as a pair of,
of blanks.
Um,
and it's precisely that blankness
that allows Nathan to inhabit Coleman.
This is in fact a quality that
he finally attributes to the,
as he says, negroes in the
photograph of Coleman's family.
And this is on three 37.
Okay,
very bottom of three 36. They
were Pale, but they were Negros.
How could you tell they were
negros by little more than that,
they had nothing to hide.
This is quite an astonishing sentence.
If identity is in its ideal form secrecy,
if you have nothing to hide,
then you don't have an identity.
There are two things, two implications
that flow from that. One is,
uh,
that racial secrecy is really the
only kind of secrecy that matters
because being Negro is the
only thing that one would hide.
Yeah.
It also means that these people are
just as blank as fornia and Coleman.
So there is a somewhat pernicious
racial simplification going on here.
It's somewhat related to the
simplification of thinking
that homeowner erotics
is the desire for the same.
What both of these logics leave out
is that point that is insistent upon
actually earlier in the novel,
which is that the other
fellow always has a life.
You can't know that it's simply the
otherness of any individual person that
keeps you from knowing more
than you can see on the surface.
It's the otherness, not the
racial otherness necessarily,
but just the otherness.
So in these last pages,
otherness gets collapsed
back into racial otherness.
And I think this is why Ernestine
emerges as a stereotyped character.
He is a folding and analysis of
identity back into racial stereotype
and analysis of identity as as blank.
They have no interiority.
One question that you could ask is
whether this constitutes a critique of
Nathan.
Is Nathan being brought to task for
stealing the story of Coleman Silk?
Is this making passing racial passing
into the ultimate form of identity?
That to be interesting as a character,
you've got to be passing a,
is it indicting Nathan?
Is it suggesting that Nathan
really does Desire Coleman?
These are all kinds of questions
that you can think about.
One thing I think it does
do though is highlight the
constructiveness of the
narrative across the board.
Coleman says about his spooks narrative
that he could not do the creative remove
that the pros do calls
the creative remove.
He says it's still the Ra thing.
It's a bad book because
it's still the raw thing.
He has no self distancing,
so what the critique of Nathan does,
the implicit critique of Nathan does is
distant sauce from him to some degree.
It allows us to see him
as an unreliable narrator.
It also,
I think models,
Roths own relation to Nathan Zuckerman.
Nathan's Zuckerman is the creative remove
is the medium of the creative remove
that Roth requires in order
to write about his own life.
Most of the Nathan Zuckerman novels
draw very heavily on Roths life.
And in fact, at one point, Roth
writes an autobiographical, uh, um,
nonfiction book called the facts
and it's all mostly about, um,
complaining about the,
uh,
response to Portnoy's complaint and
also [inaudible] against his ex wife.
Very happy habit that a Roth has.
Um,
at the end of the facts there is a letter
to Roth from Nathan Zuckerman where he
says, idiot, why are
you doing autobiography?
This is not your style facts. It's just
not your thing. Forget it. It's terrible.
Don't publish this. Go back to what
you do best, which is making stuff up.
Roth has played with this dynamic between
autobiography and fiction throughout
his career.
And I think the threat,
the deathly threat of the collapse that's
figured in the homo erotic element of
this novel is the threat of it.
It's sort of,
um,
doubles the threat of Roth
collapsing into Nathan Zuckerman.
Okay.
And in another sense,
it doubles the threat of
writing really only about men.
That what's weak about the novel is the
way that it inhabits the subjectivities
of women, especially Delphine
room is just a character really.
Um, and in many small ways
Fanya is a character too.
Um,
I've talked about Ernestine less
can be seen as a caricature.
Uh,
so it's not something exclusive
to his female characters,
but it does suggest, as I mentioned
a little while back in the lecture,
certain kind of limit to Roths project.
So I will finish by saying Roth is an
extremely important writer in this period
because of the very complexity with
which he makes the texture of his novels.
Speak to the question of fictions,
relationship to life writings,
relation to life and the relationship
between the writer and what he or she
writes the writer in the work.
These are questions that
vacs writers in this period.
We've seen many writers in this
syllabus who worry about these things.
Barth, Morrison, um, so many of them,
Maxine Hong Kingston Roth does it in a
way that nobody else particularly does.
He's also widely admired when the New
York Times had this feature a few years
ago. I think it was 2004 on the
best novels of the last 25 years.
And they pulled about 125
public intellectuals, writers,
professors of literatures,
um, reviewers and asked who,
what is the one best novel they
asked? They made it hard. He said,
what's the one best novel of the last
25 years? Well, number one was beloved.
Number two was blood meridian.
But if you added up all
the rough novels together
that people chose Roth was the winner.
Yeah.
So he's highly regarded,
although there is split opinion as you
can see there about which of his novels
is really, uh, the best one.
So I will say to you that we're tracking
in what we're reading writers who are
making an enormous impact on what American
fiction looks like in the latter part
of the 20th century.
Um,
it's very interesting to me to see the
very ambivalences that are at the heart
of this fiction. Now I'll
stop there for, uh, for Roth.
Let me just say as we go
into Edward P. Jones, um,
the novel that I don't have
on the syllabus is beloved.
It's always a novel that,
um, I hope that you've read.
I used to teach it routinely,
but it's fun to shake it up and put some
different things on knowing that a lot
of you will have read it when you read
Edward P. Jones. If you have read,
beloved,
I'd like you to think hard
about the relationship
between those two writers and,
and the two novels. If you
haven't read beloved, I urge you,
just go to Wikipedia and just get a
plot summary or open it up even better.
I won't ask you to read it on the side
extra. Uh, although I would love to, um,
find out a little bit about it just
so that you, you have it in your,
in your head, uh, as you begin
to read. Okay. Thank you.